hey guys so we have another lovely
client here and I want you to just tell
us your right knee hurts right yes I
have some pain in my knee from the right
right so how long have you had pain for
two year two years two weeks ago I have
problem a lot really was there an injury
or it just started hurting no only I
don't know I had only pain I don't know
what is maybe accident or okay
and now um does it hurt when you're
sitting or do you have to stand on it
and kind of walk and sometimes I am city
or on I sleep is difficult for me for
clothes my my knee and my problem is
when I you stand up and I yoke is
therefore it is difficult for walking
okay so just stand up right here and
just stand and then kind of like like
just kind of bend down and tell me if it
hurts and you kind of bend down does
that hurt look okay um have a seat so
give me a number ten being very severe
zero no pain give me a number I think in
the NAM or maybe seven seven okay so now
what we're going to do is I'm going to
show you how to fix the knee the only
time this would not work is if she had
an actual tear okay so now what you're
going to do is you're going to sit right
here and the way to fix the knee is we
work on the the goodness you can sit
back a little bit and we want to work on
the muscles on the opposite side so if
the pain was right here would work on
these muscles pains here we work on
these muscles and I'm talking about
pressing in here now you could do this
to yourself
if you like to put yourself in pain now
just kidding
you could work on yourself if you use
like a foam roller or a massage tool but
I'm pressing in the muscle that goes
straight in the center of the thigh okay
so now we're working on the rectus from
for us right in here
now it's interesting it's always going
to be twice as tender on the opposite
side so I do expect this to be sore so I
get to make sure if her eyeballs don't
pop out too badly right through in there
feel that right there so we want to go
right up into the hip
okay that's step one now we're going to
work on the muscle just on the outside
of that it's called the vastus lateralis
and we're going to press in there yeah
this is the one that she's been
compensating she's been putting the
pressure I like to take a broad contact
and this would be good on that foam
roller to lay on her side but I'm just
putting pressure and letting gravity do
the work I'm just leaning on it and I
know it's tender so I'm just going
gradually a broad contact right through
in here
good morning wake-up call okay so we're
just going to press here now what this
is probably the worst point right there
you feel that
now I'm going to come in on the side at
another angle right into the sides but
these are the points now while I'm doing
this go ahead and move this knee back
and forth yeah keep going back and forth
back and forth yeah mm-hmm so this
should go should feel looser now
typically what people will tell you is
they're going to say oh of course if you
step on the foot it's your cause pain
here it's not going to hurt there that's
not how this is working
we're basically sending signals back up
because both of these are on the same
circuit and they work together
I'm sending signals to the brain tell
this need to - stop stop suiting pain
signals on that side like right into the
hip we can come down here right and
there okay good so now stand up right
there and just stand out here okay so
does it feel a little better yes thank
you so much okay so what it feels what's
the number now it was at a nose now is
good you know I don't have problem now
I'm go ahead and bend down a little bit
let's see if you can bend a little bit
more yeah not too far away right there
just kind of bending see if you can bend
down a little bit yeah yeah it's not bad
wow that's actually pretty good so good
thank you so much Jefferson you're
welcome
so that's not bad for two years being or
two weeks I'm sorry being in pain but so
now we know for a fact it's not tore
because it got better fast if it didn't
get better you would want to go get it
scoped out by an ortho or something but
the fact that it got better means that
she would want to do this every day but
here's the key you want to get deep into
these points all I did is one treatment
and it took me like about two minutes
she's going to have to work on this over
and over and over because those are
knots they're like cords and you have to
work all that out over a pier - probably
one to two weeks before - just be stable
and then make sure you don't limp when
you walk like walk normally
okay but it's going to take a lot of
pressure off this neat and this knee
will actually feel like it's looser it's
more relaxed and more stable okay so are
you happy now yes and so how do you
think okay you're welcome all right go
ahead and put your comments below and I
will see you in the next video